i i just i'm trying to figure out what's
going on with ben and i'm super
supportive of ben and decision making i
feel like any time you're with the team
like the sixers that them under the bus
was clowning them fans obviously they
didn't want them to be there
under the bus
dr spiciness
doc come on doc can't be there he
defended him the whole year and then
after the last game he goes i don't know
and then ben simmons said i'm going to
play twitch for eight months
come on but all i'm saying is i'm
getting angry this is too early now
we're hearing stories like ben can't
dunk and he needs to ramp up my thing is
like what if where were you ramping up
while you were just at the crib chilling
get on hit it shut up there's a cell
phone in his pocket josiah you're more
professional than that that's ridiculous
i keep my cell phone out of me
okay uh
by the way when we see your takes we
will be i will be judging and you can
too three categories originality i don't
want to have a take that was on some
other show where you stole it energy you
can't be like well i think that james's
heart no i need the energy and spiciness
level
what would you have given my take if you
were judging it um reasonable take i'm
gonna give it a seven okay not too spicy
not too spicy believable me harder i
mean
they've been playing well so far you
know we'll see how the rest of the
season pans out obviously daryl moore
wanted to get him there very bad
and was willing to feel like he got
fleeced by the mainstream so maybe you
know something that we don't
i'm i'm really
emotional i i feel like i know what your
take is going to be about yes it is so
whenever you're ready
you know i'm a lifelong lebron fan
everybody knows that i've been been
rolling with him since 2003 he came to
ucla i played at ucla didn't play much
don't research the stats it will
disappoint you
but he sat in my chair and i said lebron
remind james
he was he was just lebron raymond james
before he was a senior at this point
intelligent man because if i walked in
that locker room had a lot of guys
didn't shower properly cheeks right on
seat never put the towel down just a lot
of stuff that was going on
i was always respectful of my chair
picked a great chair
lakers have been struggling this year i
mean you know i think everybody knows
that and it's been tough to watch uh
tough to deal with you think about last
night you guys had the game on
tnt yeah i knew right when they took
lebron out in the fourth quarter it's
over yeah like they're they're not gonna
win this game wow so they're up like
five or six what take are you about to
lay on me right now this one i'm gonna
tell you everybody thinks that i've
heard you know shout out to legend kevin
o'connor text me like oh should they
shut lebron down i said absolutely nay
nay to that
i say that the los angeles lakers will
not only make the playoffs but they will
win a series
in this postseason oh not playing a
series series i would change it if it
doesn't happen but uh i think they'll
win a series in the playoffs and again
you're not talking about the play-in not
the plan although if they are
they get like the seven or eight and
they knock off a sons or a grizzlies
wow or
warriors i think the way the basketball
guys work they're going to be super
janky you know you're talking about when
nobody's afraid of those footsteps
anymore you're going to see those
footsteps in the postseason it's going
to be a little bit different but it all
hinges on a.d's ankle we need some mr
miyagi
get in there clap it up but looking at
the squad but i will say if they
finished 9th or 10th in the west